auau-dessus du 100 $, augmentatn
dede 163 %.
R Richard Darveau, président
etet chef de la direction
dede l'Association québécoise
dede la quincaillerie et des
mamatériaux de construction.
EsEst-ce que vous pensez que çaa
cocontinuer à m monter?
-,-, Malheureusement, oui.
LeLes municipalités, les états
prprovinciaux et nationaux et le
sesecteur privé attende qu'on st
àà r rendu à un n certain taux e
vavaccination pour êtrtre encore
plplus agressif sur le marché en
gégénéral. Donc le bois et les
auautres matériaux de constructn
seseront encore plus en demande.
S'S'il y a plus de demandes, pe-
êêtre e plus de rareté, ça donne
l'l'occasion pour ceux qui les
fafabriquent de contrôleler lesx
élélevés.
- - Qui empêchche le magot
acactuellement? C'est une
exextraordinaire année pour les
prproducteurs. Est-ce que le grs
dede l'augmentation va chez le
prproducteur, chez vous, ceux qi
vevendent aux entrepreneurs? Qui
emempêchchent le magot? Soit ilt
didistinguer le bois des autres
mamatériaux. Si on isole questin
papar r rapport à
l'l'approvisionnement en bois, s
séséries ont des prix qui ont ds
prprix qui font beaucoup plus lr
afaffaire aujourd'hui, mais il
fafaut dire qu'ils ont eu des ts
mamauvaises années pendant deux
dédécennies. Autant avant c'état
pepeut-êtrtre sous leur prix de.
ilils ont eu des années à p per.
AuAujourd'hui, le mêmeme conviee
quque les prix sont un peu fort.
DaDans votre reportage, on disat
ququ'on va sûrerement arriver àn
plplus juste prix pour toutes ls
paparties. Dans les autreses
mamatériaux, c'est d'autres
prproblématiques, c'est d'autres
raraisons. On se rencontre qu'on
est vulnérable par rapport à
cecertaines s crises sociales. n
sesent le conflit qui va peut-êe
rerevenir au port de Montréal, n
sese souvient du blocage des vos
feferrées.
- - Je veux arriver aux autres,
paparce qu'effectivement, il y a
dedes pénuries de plusieurs
prproduits, mais la planche de
cocontreplaqué qui est rendu à 0
$,$, entre 30 et 100, vous dîtes
quque c'est le producteur qui en
prprend la plus grosse part, pae
ququ'il y a eu des années de
vavaches maigres?
- - Les prix un peu trop élevé,
mamais de la vie de l'ensemble s
paparties, je pense qu'on a payé
papas assez cher pendant des
anannées. Il faut juste
s's'habituer. Ça ressemble aussi
auaux valeurs des maisons parfo.
- - Les saoudiens, à u une époq,
reretenait le pétrole, on sortat
momoins pour monter les prix. E-
cece que les cours sont pleines?
EsEst-ce qu'on retient du matérl
enen haut en quelque part?
- - On va privilégier les cliens
réréguliers. Si vous arrivez coe
unun cheveu sur la soupe, ça se
pepeut qu'on vous dise non mêmee
s's'il y a du bois disponible,
paparce qu'on l'a réservé pour s
clclients fidèles.s. Je pense qe
c'c'est des bonnes affaires.
- - Les gens qui se demandent :
esest-ce qu'onon devrait se garr
dudu bois au Québec. Est-ce qu'n
dedevrait pas se garder du stoc,
paparce qu'on n'en exporte
bebeaucoup. La moitié est expore
auaux États-Unis. Est-ce qu'on
dedevrait pas s'en garder
dadavantage? Qu'est-ce que vousn
pepensez?
- - Absolument. On doit sécurisr
nonos approvisionnements et on
pepense que le bois, on devrait
l'l'élever à u un niveau qu'on
apappelle le bien commun. Ce n't
plplus qu'une comédie comme
n'n'importe quel produit
trtransigeait à l la bourse. C't
tetellement essentiel et en
paparticulier pour soutenir la
rerelance que l'on souhaite une
fofois la vaccination complétée.
AlAlors on demande au gouvernemt
dede trouver des façons de
s's'asseoir avec l'ensemble des
jojoueurs dans l'urgence pour
coconvenir d'un mécanisme qui ns
pepermettrait de sécuriser nos
bebesoins en bois en particulie.
- - Donc ça veut dire réserver s
foforêtsts publiques... est-ce y
a a des rencontres des décisions
prprévues bientôt?t? Souhaitentn
adadhérent comme prévu avec
plplusieurs cabinets ministéries
dadans les arts et les jours qui
viviennent. Vous êtes s peut-ête
bibien informé. Je pense que le
gogouvernement semble avoir
l'l'oreille très ououverte non à
seses doléances, c'est pas
nénégatif, c'est très s positife
dedemander d'être e en contrôlee
cecertains produits clés.
- - Pour pas qu'il en manque chz
nonous? Souhaite absolument. Coe
onon a peut-êtrtre trop... vous
vovouliez arriver peut-êtrtre sr
cecet autre sujet, on a trop
dédélocalisé certains composants
clclés qui font qu'il y a des
ususines qui ne tournent pas das
d'd'autres sacs par névralgies.
DaDans la peinture, les portes t
fefenêtrtres, l'industrie de la
cocolle. Je vous écoute.
- - Je vais arriver là. . Pour r
popour le bois, le roi des
ququincailleries, des bannièrer,
esest-ce que en profite aussi pr
10100 m plus, il y a plus de
prprofits?
- - Les marges sont plus petites
ququ'appareil date l'année
dedernière. . En ville comment
rururale, ils sont tellement gês
eueux-mêmemes d'acheter beaucoup
plplus cher qu'il s'apprenne des
mamarges plus petites, mais c'et
papas un problèmeme. Ils ne fons
pipitié du tout, parce que le
vovolume est là.
- - Les bois c'est une chose, ms
ilil manque de portes, de
fefenêtrtres, de lavabo...
- - c'est aussi par rapport au
chchangement climatique. Il y au
unune vague de froid au Texas au
momois de février. Ça nous a pau
ananodin, mais là-b-bas, ça a gé
totout, de la production. On n'n
sosouffre encore ici. Il y a
bebeaucoup d'usines québécoisese
poportes et fenêtrtres, fabrican
dedes pinceaux, de colle, chercr
dedes bois pour déménager, on va
apapprocher du 1er juillet et ça
sese peut que vous ayez de la
didifficulté à en n trouver, pae
quque des éléments là-dededans,
c'c'est de la colle ou différene
dede produits chimiques qu'on
prproduisait avant. En pinceaux,
onon avait de usines et on les a
papas appuyés. On ne les a pas
acaccompagnés. Elles ont fini pr
nonous quitter. Alors je pense e
c'c'est ça qu'il y a de bons avc
lala pandémie si je peux me
pepermettre, c'est que ça nous
fafait réfléchir peut-êtrtre en
grgrappe pour employer une
exexpression qui était chère  à
GéGérald Tremblay. On doit revor
lala notion d'infidélité entre
clclients et fournisseurs, penss
etet circuits courts par région,
papar secteur économique pour
ararrêteter de croire que parce
ququ'on économise quelques sous
nonoirs en délocalisant un
cocomposant au bout du monde, on
sese rend service. Quand arrivet
dedes augmentations de demandes,
onon aimerait êtrtre plus solide
leles uns des autres. Vous save,
onon était dans s le juste à t .
LLà, , il faut aller dans le jue
auau cas. On ne sait pas quelle
auautre crise sociale, climatiqe
etet économique va nous arriver.
- - C'est intéressant. Vous avez
enen tête s sur des produits qud
vovous dîtes s ça. On produise
dadavantage une pléiade de
prproduits.
- - Qu'on se rencontre pour voir
ouoù sont nos sous-traitants et
l'l'économie court terme vaut-ee
enencore la peine? On se
sosolidarise à l l'intérieur des
rérégigions. Ça aussi, c'est un
apappel qu'on fait au gouvernemt
popour nous accompagner dans ce
trtravail.
- - Ceux qui ont des rénovations
ququi ne sont pas encore entamé,
vovous leur : attendez encore ue
anannée?
- - Non, parce que l'année
prprochaine, ils vont voyager.
MMêmeme si c'est cher, il y a ds
mamatériaux disponibles. Profit-
enen, il n'y a rien d'autre à
fafair